تطورات الميدانيه لهذه الحرب اعلنت
ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه تعزيز مواقعها في
المناطق الشرقيه بالمدينه واقرت انها خاضت
معارك داريا مع الكويت قوه الاوكرانيه في
هذه المناطق من جانبه قلل المتحدث باسم
القوه الاوكرانيه في الشرق سرهيش رفاتي ان
القوات الروسيه تواصل محاوله شن هجمات
باتجاه وسط باخموت وفي البلدات المحيطه
بها مشيرا الى انها صدت اكثر من 100 هجوم
خلال الساعات الاربع والعشرين الماضيه هذا
ونشرت وكاله الروسيه صورا قالت انها
لمقاتل ميليشيا فاجنر يتجولون في حي زبخ
موتكا الذي سيطرت عليه بشرق بخمه قبل
يومين
اعلنت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه قصفا
صاروخيا روسيا استهدف منشاه بنيه تحتيه
حساسه في المقاطعه من جهتها قالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوه الروسيه قصفت
مناطق اوكرانيا عده يوم امس بنحو خمسه
وتسعين صاروخا وحذرت الهيئه من ارتفاع
مستوى التهديد الصاروخي مشيره الى استمرار
محاوله حصار ضخمه كما اكدت الهيئه فشل
القوه الروسيه في تنفيذ هجمات باتجاه
وشاختار وسط دونيتسك بينما تحاول تعزيز
مواقعها في منطقتين لمن شمال دونيسك
وكوبيان كشرقي خركيز مع استمرار القصف
المتبادل فيزاولوجيا وخيرسون
ونقلت رويترز عن مصادر تجاريه ان قيودا
امنيه تحول دون مرور ناقلات للغاز من تحت
جسر القرم في بحر ازوف وقالت المصادر ان
عده ناقله محمله بالغاز المسال لم تتمكن
من العبور تحت الجسر مما دفع المصدرين الى
استخدام طرق اخرى خارج روسيا وكان جسر
القرن قد تعرض للقصف شهر اكتوبر الماضي
وقالت موسكو ان اوكرانيا هي من نفذت هذا
الهجوم